[Música]
y me llegó al colegio donde trabajo
en villa manuelita en la zona sur de
rosario rebotaba de dos colegios
si bien ella era del barrio a sus padres
le habían mandado dos colegios del
centro de los caros
repetía por segunda vez y ya venía con
un rótulo repetido ahora y rebelde
la verdad es que no encajó muy bien en
aquel grupo humano ni con los alumnos ni
con los profesores
sin embargo en mis clases de vez en
cuando contestaba y contestaba bien
hablaba con fundamento entonces se me
ocurrió invitarla a un modelo de
naciones unidas'
la primera sorprendida fue ella no podía
creer que alguien la hubiera tenido en
cuenta para algo
los segundos sorprendidos fueron mis
colegas porque en realidad que el rótulo
de repetidora y rebelde ya había
asignado su destino para siempre y nadie
iba a mover un dedo por cambiarlo
la verdad es que en ese proyecto brillo
trabó amistad con otra chica se terminó
el bullying y su motivación la llevo muy
lejos estudiado en la ong y se insertó
laboralmente a través de un programa de
una ong
y me tenía todos los números de la
lotería del fracaso sin embargo terminó
brillantemente quinto año con casi 20
años
también les puedo contar la historia de
maría una nena del barrio triángulo en
la zona oeste su familia había perdido
casi todo en una inundación y llegó a un
programa de orquestas barriales a través
del colegio aprendió a tocar el violín
algo que a nosotros nos parece bastante
difícil y más en ese contexto sin
embargo para ella no lo fue y la
orquesta le cambió la vida a ella ya su
familia para siempre se recibió de
profesora de música pero fue por mucho
más
entró con una beca al mérito académico
en la uca hoy está terminando su carrera
y trabajando en una institución
quién iba a decir que esa nena de barrio
triángulo iba a llegar tan lejos
yo sí sé quién
su profesora de música de la orquesta
estos casos son casos reales de chicos
con nombre y apellido no son los únicos
ni tampoco son la excepción que confirma
la regla como dice por ahí algún
pedagogo
son chicos talentosos surgidos de un
contexto de vulnerabilidad y siempre que
pensamos en un contexto vulnerable
pensamos en los chicos en el barrio pero
pocas veces pensamos en los docentes en
el maestro
que tiene un maestro en la cabeza cuando
pisa por primera vez con su mochila una
escuela periférica
que tiene en la cabeza porque tenemos
ideas
tenemos prejuicios y verdaderamente
pesan mucho más los prejuicios que la
pobreza
muchas personas creen que porque un
chico nació en un contexto de
vulnerabilidad está incapacitado para
recibir una educación de calidad
es lo que yo llamo la pedagogía de la
lástima pobrecito para que le vamos a
exigir pobrecito tiene tantos problemas
para que lo vamos a sobrecargar con más
cosas mejor que vaya pasando hagamos se
la fácil
y de esa manera lo que estamos haciendo
es subestimando los escondiendo el
talento no dándole esa oportunidad está
pisando el camino del fracaso
por supuesto que tenemos problemas
la mayoría de los chicos que empieza la
secundaria no la termina el 60% van a
abandonar y de ese 40% que termina
solamente la mitad es decir dos de cada
diez lo van a hacer en tiempo y forma en
cinco años es decir que tenemos una
enorme masa de adolescentes desmotivados
y frustrados dentro de la escuela
secundaria esperando cumplir 18 años
para irse a una mba
una escuela de adultos de donde también
se van a ir porque ese esquema de
escuela para adultos tampoco fue pensado
para ellos
nosotros tenemos estos problemas y estos
desafíos y tenemos que superarlo porque
para eso somos maestros para eso somos
docentes y para eso estamos en esta
profesión
yo empecé acá hace un poco más de 30
años y pasé por todos los niveles
educativos excepto el inicial
enseñe en esta provincia y en otras
en mejores y peores condiciones casi
siempre peores
y de eso se trata de que el maestro más
preparado el que tiene más experiencia
esté en el peor lugar porque es ahí
donde más nos necesitan
un contexto de vulnerabilidad implica
dar un salto un salto de calidad y
ofrecer a los chicos una alternativa
diferente
por eso siempre asociamos ese salto con
la innovación y la innovación no es
simplemente hablar de tecnología
la innovación tiene que ver con poder
resolver problemas poner en el centro al
chico y tratar de encontrar mil y una
maneras de que aprenda
los casos de envío de maría son ejemplos
de que se puede vender vencer el círculo
de la pobreza y son chicos que cambiaron
su vida y la de sus familias para
siempre pero también innovar significa
atreverse a cambiar la forma en la que
hacemos las cosas todos los días
hace 4 años yo tenía un problema en mi
escuela de villa manuelita mis alumnos
no tienen libros ni compran apuntes y
habíamos hecho de todo
entonces se me ocurrió armar un blog
hoy es una página que se llama prof y
christina blog.com y ahí subir todos mis
contenidos pero no solo los contenidos
académicos puse ahí todo lo que yo
llevaba en mi mochila a la escuela las
películas los vídeos los juegos
pero seguramente lo más importante de
ese blog no fue tanto el contenido
académico sino una página en la cual yo
al principio no presté atención que era
una página de novedades al inicio del
blog en donde ellos se empezaron a
publicar
y sus logros
y eso fue realmente lo que hizo también
la diferencia
todos ellos tenían celulares y empezamos
a usarlos constructivamente
pero esa página de novedades hizo la
diferencia porque
les voy a contar una anécdota hace un
par de años una de mis alumnas marita
empezaba el año después de un año muy
difícil donde había perdido a su mamá
y ya empezaba el año repitiendo entonces
en una de las primeras actividades del
año
hizo un excelente trabajo con su grupo y
yo hice lo que hago siempre saqué la
foto puse la felicitación en el blog y
hasta ahí llegó lo que yo pensé que era
algo normal a la clase siguiente ella
entró a clase muy emocionada y me dijo
profe
mi papá me creyó
tenía el celular en la mano
en un ambiente en donde nadie mira los
cuadernos ni las carpetas de los chicos
esa felicitación en tiempo real en el
blog en su celular hizo que su papá la
viera y ella
renovará su autoestima
ay me di cuenta del valor que había
tenido esa pequeña mínima innovación y
desde ese momento aquella frase
mi papá me creyó para mí adquirió una
dimensión trascendente
porque realmente un chico no elige donde
nacer
a ustedes se eligieron
yo tampoco
somos unos privilegiados de estar de
este lado
un chico no elige donde nacer y está en
nosotros descubrir ese talento porque en
un contexto de vulnerabilidad
el sueño puede pasar por el fútbol pero
no por la escuela
y como decía mi abuela el que no sabes
con el que no ve entonces nadie le va a
mostrar otro camino estamos nosotros
para eso por eso es tan importante
exponer los experiencias innovadoras
inspiradoras en contacto con otros
adolescentes para que puedan descubrir
talento o vocación y animarse a elegir
un proyecto de vida diferente
cuando pensamos
en el resultado que tiene este tipo de
actividades pensamos también en cómo
están nuestras escuelas nuestras
escuelas las escuelas públicas
y las otras están muy segmentadas
aquella idea de que en la escuela
pública se mezclaban democráticamente
chicos de toda condición es historia
porque las escuelas de los barrios están
completamente segmentadas nuestros
alumnos no salen del barrio no conocen
el centro no conocen las calles no se no
se mueven solos no saben ir al centro
por eso es importante que nosotros los
ex pongamos a este tipo de experiencias
y puedan romper ese techo de cristal que
es el barrio porque una vez que
descubren el talento el barrio es una
barrera invisible por eso necesitamos
sacarlos del barrio para poder encontrar
otros caminos e inspirarse y compartir
con gente diversa
este año me tocó algo increíble algo que
yo nunca espere
tantos años de trabajar me pusieron de
pronto en dubai
y ahí me encontré con 50 maestros de
todo el mundo de diferentes razas
religiones etnias
hablamos montones de idiomas pero en
realidad teníamos un mismo idioma común
que era la pasión por mejorar la vida de
nuestros alumnos a partir de la
educación de calidad
por eso cuando me dicen que hay que
esperar 30 años o viene algún gurú de la
pedagogía a prometernos alguna cosa un
poco rara realmente yo digo no hace
falta todo eso los maestros del siglo 21
se están cambiando la historia
en dubai conocí a un montón de maestros
inspiradores tan diversos pero todos
tenían un montón de cosas en común
todos habían roto los moldes todos
habían superado barreras todos ellos
eran autodidactas en algo en tecnología
en arte en ciencia o en una mezcla de
todo eso todos habían desarrollado
nuevas formas de enseñar y de aprender y
de hecho nunca dejaron de aprender los
maestros del siglo 21 no hablan hacen
uno de esos días en dubai me encontré
escuchando a la charla de una profe del
líbano
y ahí el corazón me dio un vuelco porque
mientras ella hablaba en inglés utilizó
una frase que es la misma que yo utilizo
en castellana ella estaba describiendo
el impacto de haber sacado a sus alumnos
adolescentes de una escuela de un campo
de refugiados en un proyecto
colaborativo con chicos de otro lugar
ella hablaba de sacarlos de la caja
la misma expresión que utilizó yo al
decir sacarlos del gueto
ese momento fue mágico porque yo me di
cuenta de que dos personas tan
diferentes entonces extremos del mundo
estábamos haciendo lo mismo para
resolver el mismo problema que obedecía
diferentes causas pero el resultado era
el mismo educación de calidad para una
población vulnerable en un proyecto
común
que hermana que inspira y que une
voluntades en los chicos
por eso a la vuelta de dubai
pensé que todo eso que había vivido a lo
largo de 30 años y en esa experiencia
última tenía que servirle a alguien
a quien a tantos maestros y profesores
que están solos en nuestras escuelas
periféricas así surge la idea de la red
de educadores innovadores
una red que está pensada para apoyar
difundir las buenas prácticas para
seguir aprendiendo juntos y sobre todo
para renovar
lo que yo llamo la alianza más
importante que es entre el mundo de la
educación las ong que también nos han
acompañado y las empresas porque si a
todos les importa la educación y hablan
de responsabilidad social todos tenemos
que hacer una parte
cuando me dicen quién está cambiando el
mundo
el mundo lo está cambiando gente
ordinaria haciendo cosas extraordinarias
ahí donde la profesión
lo llevo
nos salen en las tapas de las revistas
pero sin duda todos merecen el premio
nobel de la educación muchas gracias
[Aplausos]